الاحد هو يوم عطله في تونس تتوقفوا بموجبه
جل الانشطه في البلاد الصيدليات بدورها
تخضع لهذه القاعده ويغلق معظمها ابوابه
لكن هذه المره قد يتواصل هذا الاغلاق الى
اجل غير مسمى بسبب قرار موزعي الادويه
بالجمله ايقاف تزويد الصيدليات بالادويه
هذا الاعفاء يعطى لهم من سنه 2006 لكن سنه
2022 وزاره الماليه رفضت اعطاء هذا الوفاء
مما قد يسبب لهم حجز في السيوله الماليه
قد يقدر 50% من هذا القطاع الى الافلاس
نقابه موزعي الادويه بالجمله تؤكد ان قرار
يعود الى عدم التوصل الى حلل وعدم تجديد
شهاده خصم من المورد للمؤسسات الموزعه
للادويه بالجمله على ما بيعات الادويه
للسنه اثنتين 22
ونظرا للارتفاع المتواصل للاعباء الماليه
لهذه المؤسسات ما يتسبب في ازمه خانقه
وضعيه تضرر معها نشاط الصيادله واشتكى
منها المواطن ضرر في النشاط ثم ضرار في
همم
فريتم بتاع التزاوج ويخلينا نخموف
النهارين الجايين زيد القدام نقرا حسبنا
من توامان بصوا الوفره والادويه المطلوبه
والكل
عنه وقبل في نقص في المواد الغذائيه طبعا
المس مع انت بصحتنا بصحه المواد
ثم الناس
تعاني السوق الادويه التونسيه من فقدان
قرابه 700 نوع من الدواء لكن نتوقف النشاط
التي
والتي تنطلق من اهتراء البنيه التحتيه
الصحيه ولا تتوقف عند تدني الخدمات الصحيه
ونقص الادويه ما يجعل جل المرضى يكافحون
بلا سلاح ضد الامراض وخاصه الخطيره
والمزمنه منها وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس